the very first level of demon souls
hides the best armor in the game
the best rings in the game a
best-in-class shield
and this truly broken weapon yeah
this starting setup is incredible for
every playthrough really
because its damage actually doesn't
scale with your stats
meaning you can go straight to the end
game only leveling vitality and
endurance
or alternatively you can easily
transition your build to strength
dexterity faith
and if you want to be truly overpowered
magic
so as we set off make sure you start as
the royalty class
because why not right it gives you more
max
np it gives you a ring for passive np
regeneration
and it gives you soul arrow which is
just too good choose the providential
ring as your starting gift to help with
item discovery
and go to 1-1 our first goal here is to
get two more amazing rings
at the far end of the ramparts down the
tower is the cling ring
which you should try to always equip
when you're in soul form as it gives you
back
25 percent of your maximum health the
next ring is through this fog gate
off a short drop past the stairs the
fife ring
it dramatically reduces enemy aggro
range so equip it whenever you want to
get the jump on enemies
not the other way around you pick this
up behind a strava who you need to
rescue for the brass telescope
use this telescope to watch him die
against the enemies he walks off to
fight
and then finish the job and loot the
mausoleum key this key
unlocks the door to old king duran who
you're usually supposed to fight at the
end of the game
he's guarded by a red-eye knight who is
also pretty tough
so let's cheese it aggro the knight and
lure it
all the way to the opposite end of the
ramparts
into the tower stand at this spot behind
the fence
and watch it fall to its death now you
can unlock the door
and kill old king duran no not like that
like this to get duran here
lure him until he turns around and heads
back to his crypt
he won't attack you while he's trying to
get back
unless there's unbreakable rubble in the
way so destroy all the rubble
unequip your right hand weapon and start
kicking him
headbutt him to the opposite end of the
ramparts down the tower
and 20k souls his stamina regeneration
ring
his armor and demon brant are yours you
need to be
body type b to wear this armor and it
offers one of the best resistance to
weight ratios in the game
and it puts you nice and close to that
50 equip load mark which is what you
want
without any stamina penalty either
depending on your weapon and shield you
might still
fat roll with it though so let's change
that progress through the level until
you reach the dragons
lure the red one away then run straight
back to the blue dragon grab
this item and roll off to the side this
is the ring of great strength which will
help you fast roll so equip it whenever
you get a new piece of gear that's
too heavy speaking of which while you're
here you can also pick up the purple
flame shield which
requires 22 strength to wield but offers
really great resistances to physical and
fire damage which
are the two that you want most of the
time really if you bought the digital
deluxe edition
then you would have received the hoplite
shield which is slightly better than the
purple flame shield
although you can't upgrade it so the
purple flame shield does become better
eventually
but if heavy shields aren't your style
at all then just get the heater shield
from baldwin in the nexus since this
blocks 100
physical damage and it lets you parry
but the reason that heavy shields are so
good with this build is because
demon brand doesn't scale with stats
meaning you're free to become this huge
tank with
high endurance and high vitality demon
brand instead
scales with white character tendency you
don't even need to upgrade it
but to get white character tendency you
need to kill black phantoms
which is really easy to do if you have a
buddy willing to invade and die to you a
bunch of times
you just need to be in human form they
just need a black eye
orb from killing a black phantom and you
both need to set the same password so
that you can join worlds regardless of
level
but you know ps5s are scarce right now
so here are two other
overpowered weapon options the dragon
longsword
which is better if you want to play as
pure melee and the crescent
falchen which is better if you plan on
levelling magic
first though you should pick up the
crescent faction in 4-1
use your fists to carefully take out the
skeletons along the path
until you reach the castle wall here
turn left
avoid the trap then continue to the left
until you're back out again
and in front of you as an enemy too
tough to fight so roll past him and
take your prize crescent weapons like
this
scale with your magic stat they deal
magic damage and they grant mana regen
over time which helps you to switch away
from your fragrant ring
it's such a powerful upgrade path so
let's get all the materials to upgrade
it
before we leave the shrine of storms
first run back to the main gate
run across the ramparts down and loot
this key
we need this to rescue graver of oblige
who is locked in a cell
past the demon vanguard run past it drop
down
and rescue oblige at the end of the
corridor
once that's done go back to where you
got the key for his cell
and roll over this section of wall to
perform the adjudicator skip
which allows you to easily reach the
first boss of this area
be sure to kill the crystal lizard here
and any you find in this level
because they drop the upgrade materials
you need for your weapon then move on
and defeat the boss
after this oblige will appear in the
lower hallway selling you a long bow and
arrows which are just invaluable in
demon souls
case in point we use them immediately to
snipe the reaper
in the adjacent room this will reward
you with a ton of souls
and you've just unlocked an amazing
farming route as you can jump off the
nearby cliff
and repeat this again collecting your
souls on the way through
the reaper also drops moonshade stone
shards and
chunks if you're lucky and obliged sells
shards
so by the time you're done you'll have
thousands of souls
and a lot of crescent falcon upgrade
materials
alternatively you can explore further to
look for more crystal lizards there's
another one in this area
it's up the stairs here and through an
illusory wall here
with enough moon shade stone you can get
your crescent falcon to plus four easily
and even plus five if you found a pure
moonshade stone from a lizard
before we leave the shrine take this
chance to survive patch's trap in the
room below the reaper
he becomes an invaluable consumable
vendor in the nexus and
the black phantom below drops another
moonshade stone chunk
since the crescent falchion does a ton
of magic damage it's the best option to
take you through
the first level of stone fang tunnels
where you can find ed to upgrade it
when you come to this laneway with the
fire lizards in the room to the right
continue straight through the rubble and
unlock the elevator
ed is below and will upgrade your
crescent valchen
complete the first level of stone fang
tunnels and as you do be sure to kill
all the bag
carrying miners for their hard stone and
sharp stone
by the time you're through you'll have
enough of this to upgrade your shield to
plus 4
which will help reduce the amount of
stamina damage you take when you block
and if you don't plan on levelling magic
the powerful weapon that we'll get here
is the dragon longsword
found in the second stage of the
stonefang tunnels since it's on the
dragon upgrade path it doesn't scale
with your stats
instead it just adds a ton of raw fire
damage with every upgrade
the upgrade stones to get it to plus 4
can also be found
on the way to it so let's get those as
well from the almond spider archestone
take the left tunnel then go down the
elevator one tunnel here has a black
phantom that drops some dragonstone
chunks so try to kill them both and then
just take the opposite tunnel until you
get to a fog gate
and progress down the left hand side to
find the filthy man who sells dragon
stone shards
so come here with a lot of souls also
make sure you survive patch's trap here
again by killing the bear bug
with magic damage you want to keep
patches as a vendor and
bear bugs have a chance at dropping more
dragonstone once you're done go down the
cliff face until you reach these worm
monsters
go back into the narrow tunnel and hug
the left wall until you get to a bear
bug
lure it out run past it until you get to
a crevasse
fall in take the left path again hug the
left wall again
and you'll find your prize some of these
tunnels lead out to a lava river and
when you find it
pick up these chunks that should be
enough dragonstone for a plus 4 upgrade
at the blacksmith which
is pretty crazy for this early in the
game you'll see
having both weapons is good some enemies
are weak to fire some magic
but regardless if you chose one or the
other let's
round out your character with some
insane magic upgrades
since spells in demon souls don't
require stats
using at least some magic is beneficial
for most builds
so before you leave fang pick up the
crisp blade
on this platform found up the elevator
right before you fight the armored
spider
have it equipped in one hand while your
catalyst is in the other
and it will boost the amount of magic
damage that you do
while you're back in the nexus grab
flame toss from frake's apprentice
you're better off using fire damage in
some places like latria
where we'll be heading next to rescue
sage frake
and get even more amazing spells from
him
so first progress as you normally would
through this level until you come
to the main cathedral behind the volley
of arrows
take the stairs up on the right and take
the special key behind the praying
dregling
who you should kill and then go on to
defeat the boss
afterwards if you find yourself on the
top floor of latria during your
exploration as well
open one of the iron maidens in this
room that has four of them
to get the ring of magical sharpness
which increases your magic damage
so now that we have the key we can open
frake's cell
from the arch stone turn right go up the
stairs
go to the other end of the hallway go
outside
go back in hug the left wall then run to
the opposite side again go downstairs
one level
and look to the cells on the right there
he is after this
he'll appear back in the nexus offering
a greater selection of spells
in exchange for boss souls your new main
spell at this point
should be soul ray which pierces through
enemies and does a ton of damage
and warding a defensive spell that takes
up two slots but reduces
physical damage taken by an insane 70
percent
while it's active this means you can get
in thick of it as a mage build which is
great
for these spells you'll need the fool's
idol soul and the tower knight soul
so if you've done everything in this
guide you'll have everything you need
really at this point
to comfortably beat the game your
character at this point
doesn't really need to invest in
anything other than vitality
and endurance really but like i said
earlier this means you can comfortably
build towards whatever else you'd like
to try as you play through the game
some of my favorite basic weapons are
the uchigatana
found past the demon vanguard in 4-1 the
claymore sold by the dregling vendor in
1-2
the great club across this broken
platform in 2-1
the winged spear on the first bridge in
1-2
and the crushing battle axe up the
elevator at the start of 2-1
hell with the magic damage and fire
defense shields mentioned in this video
flame lurker is so easy so you can also
take this opportunity to just
get his soul and build a boss weapon
build without beating any of the other
content
so whether you're experienced at this
game or whether you're a new player
this is just such good fundamental
knowledge for demon souls that
i figured it would be helpful to
everybody so if this video gets enough
likes
or if it's just well enough received i
might go on to do a fun
build guide video there are just so many
great ways to play this game
so subscribe for that build video if
you're interested
and while you're grinding this out you
should consider opening up audible and
listening to
the name of the wind by patrick rothfuss
an
audiobook that you can listen to for
free during your 30-day audible trial
i'm going to play you a sample and while
you listen go and visit audible.com
or text vaatividia to 500-500 and you
can start your free trial right now
here's an excerpt from an early chapter
i even found a part about demons
chronicler relaxed there's no such thing
as demons
from his tone it was obvious he'd said
the same thing many many times before
the redhead man gave an incredulous
laugh
i guess we can all go home then he
flashed a manic
grin at chronicler listen
i'm guessing you're an educated man i
respect that and for the most part
you're right
his expression went serious but here and
now
tonight you're wrong wrong as
wrong can be the name of the wind is
such a good one to listen to
i bet a ton of people in the comments
can actually vouch for that
remember though your membership also
includes audible plus which grants
unlimited access to thousands of select
originals audiobooks and podcasts so
no matter what you're into they've got
it so again
please go and visit audible.com or text
device video to 500 500 to get started
today
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video and thank you for watching